if you want to heal something naturally
rather than putting a Band-Aid on it
with a medication it takes a long time
and I can vouch for that because all of
my symptoms they didn't just go away
overnight in an instant but then all the
other issues with anxiety and stress a
lot of that in hindsight looking back
the more that I talk about my story I
feel like so much of that was truly just
due to you know why would I expect to
feel good if I'm not doing good things
for myself it's such a simple answer
when I look back at it now you can't
show up as your best self in the world
when you're not feeling great from a
multitude of symptoms like migraines or
you know stomach issues skin issues like
all these types of things it affects the
way that you feel on just going out into
the world food is definitely like the
entry point that I think most people
should start at when we're talking about
getting back to the basics like I said
and that's why our Channel and our brand
is eat move rest because they're the
three things that we all do every day
that we could all be doing better food
is the portal but then if you're eating
healthy clean Foods you have energy to
exercise which can further help your
digestion your sleep your anxiety your
mood your hormones everything it's not
just the food but the food is kind of
the most important because we do have to
do that multiple times a day no matter
what the smooth slow transition I find
it's like the best way to make it stick
because then you're learning how to
replace common recipes and items like
different produce items instead of
animal products so slow and steady and
then over time like a train from a
standstill it takes it a while to get
starting but once it does it has that
momentum and you'll kind of find your
flow
that was Aaron stanzic from the popular
YouTube channel eat move rest where her
and her husband Dusty share all things
food Fitness and mindfulness Aaron is a
mom of two and passionate plant-based
eater who grew up in Nebraska and moved
her family to Florida this last year and
in this episode Aaron shares her health
and transformation story we also get
into what eating plant-based in a cold
climate can look like and talk about
life on social media raising healthy
kids and how she chose to start over and
get back to the basics in her life Aaron
and I have a lot in common and it was so
nice to get into an intimate
conversation between us moms who are on
a similar path in life and passionate
about the same core values I love
sharing this time with her I hope you
enjoyed this conversation welcome to the
Ellen Fisher podcast
so I just got a new safe sleeve for my
phone which is a 5G EMF radiation
protection case and I'm super stoked
about it safe sleep offers
anti-radiation products designed to give
you the Peace of Mind of knowing you and
your devices are protected while making
them even easier to use all of their ant
anti-radiation products incorporate lab
tested shielding technology that can
block over 99 percent of RF and 92
percent of Elf radiation there are very
few anti-radiation brands that offer lab
tested protection theirs is publicly
available on their website and maybe one
to two others that block elf elf is much
harder to block but equally as important
and all of their cell phone cases
provide military grade drop protection
which is also tested by a third party
evaluator not only that these cases come
in different colors to suit your
favorite style and there's even a place
for your bank cards and cash so
everything is in one easy to use place I
got the detachable case for my iPhone
which turns into a stand and includes
the ability to magnetically remove the
protective inner case for car mounting
and safe sleeve also has cases for your
tablet and laptop too and I got a
discount code for you guys so you too
can protect yourself from EMF radiation
with safe sleeve click my link below and
enter the code ln10 to get 10 off your
safe sleep purchase
thank you Aaron for being here I'm super
excited for this conversation how are
you liking your trip in Hawaii I mean
you just got here last night
so far so good it's beautiful it's balmy
it's Lush everything that we love about
Hawaii so we're enjoying it and thanks
for having me yeah of course we had a
nice dinner last night on the deck we
very similarly I think so it's really
easy and fun to just share meals
together I mean it's fun to share meals
with people who also don't eat like you
because then you're like do you like it
when you're like a plant-based health
nut vegan foodie it's it's kind of funny
like being in the social media world
like I'll watch your videos like even
from like day one I I remember showing
Dusty my husband I'd be like see look
she's like my food twin she's my food
twin and I found a couple people not
very many out there but you're one of
them so it's fun to get to eat with you
guys yeah the food that we had last
night was like our favorite kind of food
like what we love to make at home so
anyone wondering we had creamy coconut
lentils with rice and avocado on top and
uh sauerkraut so super good so the kids
loved it too so yes it's also really fun
to have people over who don't eat like
you and I'm always like we gotta make it
extra good I'm like what do you think do
you like it do you like it there's a guy
that we know that recently mature who's
like actually moved here to like do
ranching here and um he like definitely
doesn't normally eat vegan food but he's
like stayed in our Hana for a few days
and he's like a friend of ours and then
so we made them like we made him tacos
and all these things like what do you
think so good right he's like yes it's
very good he's from Kentucky yeah that
would actually be a good YouTube Talk
topic I've thought of is like the one
meal I would make to and for a non-vegan
like what is that one meal that you
could wow anybody with yeah what would
you think it is
um I we make a good lasagna but I also
just think like a good curry like that
like a super stew or Curry like that
with just tons of veggies and like the
right spice combination will always get
people hooked yes lasagna is a win like
if you have a good lasagna like how
could someone be like this is missing
something you know well I mean some
people would but I think tacos is a way
for us like tacos and burritos because
you have so many choices we have the
beans like that we'll make from scratch
and Andrew makes really good beans and
then we have Mexican rice and you know
guacamole you have like cilantro and
different kind of salsa lettuce yeah
cashew sour cream and they're always
like what is this I'm like it's made of
cashews it's just cashew and garlic
water and salt and like people are
always like Amazed by it and then pick
your tortilla I feel like you really
can't go wrong with that for sure yeah
like every component by itself is so
simple and easy to just like throw on a
dish but then when you put it together
people are like how did you do that yeah
totally so let's get into your vegan
story a bit I've actually never heard it
I don't know your story and what led you
to this path of eating whole plant foods
and I'd love to hear your story about it
okay cool
I I'll probably take it back to around
like high school and college kind of
that transition stage that's when I kind
of derailed I guess you could say
in high school I have one brother just
one sibling my brother and I were high
school athletes we were straight A
students on honor roll and very involved
and just you know normal high school
kids doing our thing my mom and dad
for great parents no complaints there
um we very much ate the full spectrum of
the standard American diet so we were
eating out at restaurants and eating
chicken nuggets but my mom was also
making us healthy smoothies after Sports
practice and salads and things like that
so we got a little bit of everything in
the mix
and my mom was always asking me to help
in the kitchen but I never showed an
interest I was the opposite of domestic
I was a little bit of like a tomboy Tom
girl
um so then when I got to college I like
actually derailed
um
I was in the dorm rooms uh
honestly all I had in my dorm was beef
jerky ramen noodles the standard College
diet a carton of milk in the
refrigerator which I don't know why so
um I just think oh you're supposed to
buy this you don't put it in the dorm
rooms you're living off of either
cafeteria food which there was not very
many healthy options or you're living
off of fast food and I started to stay
out late party super hard
um got really into drinking and just
like you know Facebook was a new thing
and it was like how many friends can I
make and how many friends can I acquire
on on Facebook this new thing and and it
just kind of cascaded from there it got
worse and worse and I was like sleeping
in the blinds would be closed all day no
sunlight whatsoever I was no longer in
sports and I wasn't exercising I
basically wasn't doing anything that my
moms were my mom and dad were prodding
me to do through high school and it
started to catch up with me and I feel
like that's when my first bouts of
anxiety and stress and even feelings of
depression came started to creep in
um my grades began to suffer which was
really disheartening being this type a
person
um and I just remember after one night
of partying looking in the mirror and
being like I don't really recognize
myself physically or mentally or
emotionally inside either and it was
just really starting to eat me up inside
and I was like okay I told I told my
roommate because I'm like I don't know
what this is like I just don't feel like
myself and she didn't either and
so we decided okay well let's maybe
start going to the college Rec and
working out that's usually where people
look first not food they are always
looking to Fitness so we just sort of
decided to start exercising and as the
saying goes you can't really out train a
bad diet
um
so you know I was on this I I kind of
got on this hamster wheel where I was
working out really hard during the week
but then it would come to like thirsty
Thursday and then Friday and Saturday
and even Sunday sometimes of like
drinking and going out again and then I
would try and like reverse the damage
during the week and it was just this
vicious cycle that was wearing on me I
was on academic honor roll in high
school like I said and then I went on
academic probation freshman year where
it's like if your grades don't get up go
up you you can't go to school here so
again it was just like everything was it
was just starting to compound and I
became increasingly unhappy and unsure I
couldn't the exercise wouldn't fix it
and towards the end of college I
actually
um
reconnected with my now husband Dusty we
had known each other in high school just
through mutual friends we reconnected
and started hanging out
and he knew how to cook and he liked to
cook and we we were just friends at
first we didn't want to be more than
friends but we would hang out and he but
he was all about the protein really
really pushing the protein the animal
protein so I was then eating even more
meat than ever before more animal
products than ever before and I became
increasingly concerned about my protein
intake yep so we were eating healthier
on one hand because we were making
things together at home more and more
and less and less fast food
um but still I still wasn't feeling good
like whatsoever in fact most of my
symptoms
um progressed Beyond just the mental
health issues to a lot of physical
issues as well
so it started with just like kind of a
lethargy brain fog lots of mood swings
and then hormonal imbalances with
irregular periods and had to get on
hormonal birth control and that comes
with its own set of symptoms
and then it progressed even further into
like numbness and tingling and I was
always a hypochondriac so I would always
turn to Dr Google for advice and the the
thing that's unfortunate about that is
it was kind of like Dr Google was my
best friend but also my worst enemy
because it was always telling me the
worst case scenarios so what I was
coming up with based on the the symptoms
I was researching was multiple sclerosis
and other autoimmune type conditions and
it just gave me this sinking feeling in
my gut like I didn't know what to do and
um coming from a family of doctors my
dad being a family physician and having
cardiologists all around me and all
kinds of Specialists it was very easy
access for me to get lined up with
getting my blood work done getting all
kinds of testing done so I had a CT scan
multiple MRIs a nerve conduction study
which still to this day I can't tell you
exactly what that was for
um
and so all of the doctors and
Specialists came back reporting the same
thing it's just anxiety it's just panic
disorder it's all in your head no real
actual diagnoses you know they didn't
find any lesions on my brain lending to
multiple sclerosis
so you would think that that was like a
sigh of really like nothing's wrong with
me but it didn't really fix things
because I was most definitely in a state
of dis-ease even though I didn't have a
labeled diagnosis
and so I decided okay I'm gonna go back
to the drawing boards and like Dusty is
with me through all of this we're still
trying to be super healthy we began like
cycling and riding bikes constantly
um trying to eat as clean as we could
taking all of the supplements just
pounding the supplements
um
trying to heal trying to find a source
of relief I was having a lot of
breathing issues because of it and I
feel like it was partial panic and
anxiety but also
just so much inner turmoil just like I
felt this density inside of me and what
I really needed was lightness and like a
ray of light like a breath of fresh air
and so
went back to drawing boards got back on
Google and I'm like no more searching
symptoms you're not getting the answers
that you want or need like let's search
Solutions yeah and so I did come upon a
few things about you know food as
medicine food as you know a means to
Healing even just digestion which I
should mention is another big one that
probably a lot of people can relate to
is poor digestion extremely sluggish and
if you're not going regularly like
you're just not going to be in a good
mood let's put it that way so true yep
not on a plant-based diet like you'll
get enough fiber I was I had I should
mention this too I had a fiber Obsession
as I was getting healthier trying to
figure out the digestive things
I was counting grams of fiber like I was
but I would go to the store
I would look for Fiber One bars Fiber
One yogurt Fiber One cereal that's just
like going straight to the source of
legal Cuisines I was making sure they
were low calorie Lean Cuisines but also
high fiber ones yeah and so everything I
was looking for I was like I'm I'm
looking on the label for grams of fiber
so that means I'm buying processed
packaged Foods because produce doesn't
have a label on it yep and that's all I
had to do was just shift my focus and
just eat all the plant Foods in the
plant kingdom but I wasn't quite there
yet
um but this is a good thing this is a
good part so my uncle who's a
cardiologist kind of dabbled in the
plant-based vegan thing and he invited
my whole family and Dusty and I to go
listen to a doctor speak at a local
hospital so we went and listened it was
Dr esselstyn Who I had no idea who he
was at the time just last teeny tiny
little Nebraska hospital so cool and
being that I had
um I was going to school for biology I
had my biology degree so seeing on the
screen him showing these echocardiograms
and showing people's heart disease
literally being reversed
was like mind-blowing to me and it all
made sense to me it just clicked in my
head from like that scientific
standpoint
and then afterwards he fed us like his
healthy bean sprout quesadillas and all
kinds of weird hippie vegan food that we
weren't familiar with and my uncle was
like you guys should try it just try it
for a month see how you feel so we
decided okay let's do it for 40 days but
plant-based is still a little extreme so
let's just dip our toes into the water
and do vegetarian for 40 days so we did
that and it was fine by me because I was
still a reluctant Chef I'm like if I
don't have to touch a slimy wet piece of
raw meat ever again in my life that'd be
golden so it was actually like a relief
for me like wow we can actually Thrive
this way not just survive but Thrive and
not have to cook all this yucky food and
like disinfect the countertops all the
time
all right you guys who wants dry
cracking skin when you could have smooth
hydrated and Youthful looking skin did
you know that skin cracking happens when
your skin loses so much moisture that it
breaks down most people develop cracked
skin on their feet hands and lips but it
can affect any part of your body enter
osea if you know me at all you know I am
obsessed with asea which is a Clean
seaweed-based Skin Care brand I
incorporate their products every day in
my morning and evening self-care rituals
including the ocean cleanser hyaluronic
sea serum and day glow face oil and
lately I've been obsessed with her and
Daria algae body butter which is
essential for my winter body care
routine it's clinically proven to
hydrate for 72 hours and it firms and
minimizes the look of crepiness leaving
the skin soft smooth and supple and it
smells amazing it has this uplifting
Citrus scent that smells like summer
first I prep my skin with a dry brush
then after my morning shower I use the
undaria algae body butter all over my
skin which is so luxurious especially
for those of you living in a cold
climate with dry weather the indaria
algae butter butter will be a game
changer for you and for a limited time
you can get 10 off with my code Ellen
underscore uabb just click the link
below in my show notes to get this deal
[Music]
and
Dusty on the other hand by the end of it
he went right back through the
drive-through to celebrate with his
Burger yep and I was like I kind of
liked it you know like why don't we just
do or we like we continue to not bring
it into the house but if we go out to
dinner you can like treat yourself and I
would like get like a filet of salmon or
something like that but eventually like
we just started to educate ourselves
more we found a couple of conferences to
attend they were healthy lifestyle
coaching conferences
um we got our certifications in the
process
um and then we went to an actually
full-blown plant-based conference so we
really were arming ourselves with all of
the knowledge while we were actually
gradually progressing and
um growing in it you know with different
recipes we were creating so over time
the dairy just kind of slipped away and
then at the end like still having this
protein protein protein mindset eggs
were like the last thing we were like
clinging to so it was like
okay let's have scrambled eggs for
breakfast and let's put eggs over easy
on our plates for lunch and
um coming from a family with a history
of heart disease both on my mom's side
and my dad's side I would go in get my
blood work done we were becoming Health
nuts we were like let's go get our blood
work done and see if we get a good a
good score or whatever you know like
being that again that type a straight a
mindset yep get my blood work done and
my cholesterol is super high and my dad
and his nurses both agreed I should
probably get on a Statin drug he's on
one my mom's on one you're like how old
um mid-20s wow and I was like okay fine
but I don't like medicine so I don't
really want to do it so like how long
like how long will I have to do this and
they're like well probably forever and
I'm like are you kidding me I'm in my
20s I'm like I'm a I should be a happy
healthy normal individual and so come to
find out you know like continuing this
plant-based research I'm just like okay
they say that it could be dietary
cholesterol and we know that eggs are
like one of the biggest sources so I'll
cut it out for 30 days cholesterol was
in what Dr Greger would call the heart
attack proof range after that so that's
amazing it was just continuing like to
add fuel to the fire saying this is this
is right this feels like truth this
feels like light I'm feeling lighter
less dense like I had wanted
um and then kind of stripping back the
things like all those supplements all of
the hormonal birth control and really
truly getting back to the basics which
was the foundation of eat move rest
which is what we do now online
so it took a long time if you want to
heal something naturally rather than
putting a Band-Aid on it with a
medication it takes a long time and I
can vouch for that because
all of my symptoms they didn't just go
away overnight in an instant you know
like the blood work thing
um but then all the other issues like
the anxiety and stress a lot of that in
hindsight looking back the more that I
talk about my story I feel like so much
of that was truly just due to
you know why would I expect to feel good
if I'm not doing good things for myself
it's such a simple answer when I look
back at it now yeah and just the stress
of not feeling well like that adds
stress because you know you don't feel
well and you want to figure out why and
you can't show up as your best self in
the world when you're not feeling great
like when you just you know from a
multitude of symptoms like migraines or
or you know stomach issues like skin
issues like all these types of things
like it affects the way that you feel on
just going out into the world especially
as a young person when you don't truly
know who you are yet and you already I
mean I was such a deathly shy anxious
person already that having all these
like insecurities that I was basically
putting on myself just made it even more
difficult and then having physical
symptoms like the brain fog and feeling
like I honestly couldn't formulate like
uh a rational thought
it's like when you're socially anxious
and you don't feel good in your brain
you it just it was crippling yeah and
then at night too I was Sleepless most
nights because I would wake up
breathless with this like dense feeling
that I just could not Shake yeah and
it's like a mouse wheel like it just
goes round and around like the you know
not feeling well might make it harder
for you to want to work out and not
working out not getting Sunshine because
you don't feel well and you're laying in
bed makes it harder to sleep at night
and all that stuff just keeps going
around around and making everything
worse and worse yeah for sure and so how
did
um like your digestion like what were
some of the best things that you found
really helpful for you for anyone
listening I'd recommend you guys go back
and listen to my episode with Dr will
bolsowitz or I have two episodes with
him
um he's like a world-renowned
gastroenterologist and he's got amazing
advice for having optimal digestion and
I definitely have found that to be like
the best benefit of or one of the best
benefits of eating like a really healthy
Whole Foods plant-based diet like I just
feel amazed you know you shouldn't have
to think about your bathroom exactly
like it's like something that you don't
even think about throughout your day and
for people who struggle with gut issues
will fully attack like um testify and
explain like you know share how
difficult it is to just go throughout
your life if you don't feel well in your
in your gut in your stomach oh for sure
yeah it was definitely like I would say
the number one source of like my
moodiness it was like
waking up in the morning not knowing if
you're gonna go to the bathroom that day
or not like let's be honest like we can
we can talk about this we should be able
to talk about poop yeah yeah we all do
it we all have to do it and you should
be doing it every day and I think what
helped me a lot like I said was just
when you walk into the grocery store a
lot of times the first place you'll see
is the produce section like that should
be where you're doing like 90 upwards of
90 of your shopping experience shopping
for foods that don't have labels and the
counting the fiber grams like that just
dissipated once I realized I can blend a
healthy smoothie which I think smoothies
were like the biggest portal like I'm
still like a smoothie-aholic a smoothie
obsessed person anyone who follows our
Channel knows like green smoothies every
single morning without fail almost and I
think that really helped us we um when
we like like I said first when we went
plant-based we had gotten a blender for
our wedding and it sat in the Box for
like the first year and then we're like
okay finally open it should we try this
thing and then like the rest was history
like it's just such a great way to get a
Powerhouse of fruits veggies leafy
greens and even superfoods if you want
to add those in there and if you don't
have a taste for a lot of these Foods
it's like the best way to start to like
seed your gut and introduce your gut so
that your palate in time will learn to
desire those Foods yeah and Dr B talks a
lot about like slow and steady is the
way for people to have gut issues
because someone might say well I can't
do a whole smoothie that would just
disrupt my whole digestion for the whole
day and so he talks about like slow
instead of adding little bits at a time
so maybe you're having your whatever
meal you're used to but you're adding in
a little bit of apple or different kinds
of fruit here and there and then figure
out ways to include little more a little
bit more greens than you normally do
throughout your day um like in a meal
you're already having or including more
beans and all that so all that stuff I
think is really helpful but yeah yeah we
love smoothies too it's a great way for
me to get in a lot of greens especially
as like a busy mom without having to
think a lot about it you know because I
I love my wonderful big salads but there
isn't much time these days that I'm able
to just sit down and eat like a really
large salad and chew slowly and be
really present food you know yeah so I
love to be able to make salad or to make
green smoothies and just eat lots of
greens in them yeah with lots of greens
in the smoothie for sure and I feel like
all of these issues that like food is
definitely like the entry point that I
think most people should start at like
when we're talking about getting back to
the basics like I said and that's why
our our Channel and our brand is eat
move rest because they're the three
things that we all do every day that we
could all be doing better food is the
portal but then if you're eating healthy
clean Foods you have the energy to
exercise which can further help your
digestion your sleep your anxiety your
mood your hormones everything and so if
then if you're moving you're exhausting
your body a healthy amount so that you
can rest better at night which is also
going to improve your digestion and all
these other symptoms so it's like it's
not just the food but the food is kind
of the most important because we do have
to do that multiple times a day no
matter what so if you can eat move rest
and create a better hamster wheel to be
on then you start to truck like where at
first I feel like a lot of times it does
feel like a trudge and you feel like
you're stuck in the weeds with the food
but if you can give yourself time to
transition it doesn't have to be cold
turkey overnight like especially us
Americans want everything to be black
and white overnight but the smooth slow
transition I find is like the best way
to make it stick because then you're
learning how to replace common recipes
and items like different produce items
instead of animal products so slow and
steady and then over time like a train
from a standstill it takes it a while to
get starting but once it does it has
that momentum and you'll kind of find
your flow right and what do you how do
you respond people who have messages for
you or questions like obviously like you
like you're not a doctor you're not a
nutritionist like this aspect but when
someone's like look I'm working on the
plant-based diet it's going but like I
feel like I'm just not quite like
getting that optimal result what kind of
tips do you like to give that really
helped you get to that place of healing
over time
honestly I think it is just time and
also going back to
educating yourself and re-educating
yourself and like making small tweaks is
what really has always helped me so
there's tons of different webinars and
like
channels like yours for you know you're
not a doctor either but like you have
doctors on your channel who you can hear
from and provide a platform for to share
helpful information so I just always go
back to like the research and reminding
myself to stay the course and stay the
path and keep tweaking and making small
changes like that yeah because you'll
you'll gather new information and figure
out like what works best for you like oh
yes that information is something I
hadn't considered before and keep
tweaking things for sure I think that's
really helpful I think a lot of people
think when they go plant-based it means
automatic invincibility you know like
you're never gonna get sick you're
always going to be regular and we still
have times where we do get a cold or the
flu or have irregular digestion like I'm
not perfect you know and I still get
pimples and I still have insecurities
like you know I think that's a helpful
reminder too is that there is no perfect
diet there is no perfect way to be in
this world because we live in a broken
world yeah and our body is always giving
us messages for sure and I think
sometimes people can you know expect
that whoever there's what they're
watching oh they must be like 100
perfect here or there but there is never
there's not anybody no social media
influencer or doctor nutritionist like
no one feels 100 perfect 100 of the time
no one on any diet like so just let that
down let that go there really is not
anyone yeah for sure because our body is
giving us signals where all we like our
emotions are super super impactful in
the way we feel in our health so
whatever types of things we need to heal
from our emotional standpoint as well
and plays a big role and I want to go
back to
um when you were talking about oh just a
little bit here and holding on to
certain animal Foods it reminds me of
Andrew because Andrew and I have like
our story I don't know if you know much
about like our story but I was the one
that like got into the health stuff but
Andrew and I had been together have been
together since we were 15 and 16 so when
I had gone to him one day like babe I'm
gonna go vegan and he's like what what
are you talking about don't ever expect
me to do that and he was like super into
the whey protein and the milk and you
know in and out burger and all that
stuff but over time he saw like how my
health started to restore I started to
feel so well in my mind and my body and
he wanted to do it too like he just
started okay I'm gonna I'm gonna try
this green smoothie thing let me let me
see here I'll make a creatures look let
me let me try some of that salad that
you're having you know and he would
start having a little bit more and then
there was a time where you know he got
an In-N-Out burger and I was with my
salad that I brought with me and I'm
like feeling all good afterwards like
yeah I feel great and he's like oh gosh
I feel slug actually I don't feel good I
should have had the salad
you know so then he's starting to see
that type of thing and over time he got
to this place where he was eating pretty
much all plants like except for maybe
once every couple weeks and he'll go to
his friend's house the guys and they
would like barbecue and watch sports or
something and then they're just having
to be a time where he didn't he didn't
um like go to the friend's house for I
think it was a couple months something
like we were busy or something and he
ended up going and onward or driving
again I'm like are you gonna have the
burger and it had been like a couple
months where he was just eating taller
plant-bases like nah no no because he
just knew how he felt afterwards and he
never felt great in his body and so it's
super nice to have that Journey
um together but I know that's not
everyone's story some people some people
it's like my like my sister and
different people were like they're kind
of on it on their own and so that is a
little bit different do you ever get
messages like that oh for sure all the
time like people asking like what do you
do if your spouse isn't on board and we
get a lot of people on our Costa Rica
Retreats who it's like a wife comes
without their husband she's like oh I
could never talk talk him into coming
with me on this you know he needs his
burgers and things like that so I do
really feel for those people out there
who are doing it alone but it's even
more Testament to them and like like
yeah being able to do it on your own
yeah um and anyone should just go check
out my sister's Channel Hannah McNeely
because she's got some great tips and
advice for that because that's where
where she's at so do you have any
thoughts on eating vegan in a cold
climate because you were born in
Nebraska lived there most your life
right until just this last year yeah
moved to Florida what was it like eating
plant-based in Nebraska and what advice
do you have for people who are living in
a really cold climate and also who want
to stick to more locally grown Foods you
know just yeah that aspect yeah for sure
we were so lucky to have a really
amazing farmers market so I would say
first and foremost like if you want to
eat seasonal and local and usually
pretty clean organic food like check out
a local farmers market that's going to
be your best bet and that's only going
to be available certain times of the
year right and then as far as like other
Foods in a cold climate like we honestly
we made a video on like how we live a
tropical lifestyle in the midwest but I
know that's not possible for everybody
but we did our best yeah so what did you
do
um you know we just tried to buy
whatever fruit and veg was in in season
at the time so you'd be surprised during
the winter months you can get a lot of
really good Citrus and foods like
pomegranate and things like that and
that would be like mainly for people who
are living close to a store that's like
like Whole Foods or something right
because there's also people who are in
places where they don't maybe like a
Whole Foods or something like that is
like two hours away and that's not
possible but for the situation you were
in like how far away were you from like
a Whole Foods about 10 minutes okay so
that means but if that was out of the
question you know there's still like
you're gonna find your root veggies and
your cruciferous vegetables like you
know your collards and kale and broccoli
and cauliflower but these are all kind
of like
like I almost feel like fruits and
vegetables are like bonus foods like if
you want like the really like sustaining
foods that like some of the blue zones
of the world are thriving on you have to
look to the cheapest and most easily
accessible foods that you can buy in
bulk like oats
beans whole grains we usually buy our
oats like and put them in a giant tote
in our pantry because we use rolled oats
for our oatmeals for breakfast we make
waffles we make all of our baked goods
like brownies and muffins and things
like for the kids like you can either do
veggie muffins or like Fruity strawberry
muffins
um and then like I said like grains and
beans like every other day of the week
almost every two days I'm like the first
thing I've started to do in the mornings
is like what Bean am I gonna soak today
and we'll like base our meal around that
so I'm like black beans so then maybe
that night we'll have Buddha Bowls for
the next two days and then after that
I'll soak chickpeas and maybe we'll do
like a curry so you know the more I
think about that question like we're
really basing our meals around the rice
the quinoa the beans the oats and the
fruits and veggies like even if you
can't find them fresh you can get them
Frozen most places to add on top of all
of these meals or to blend for smoothies
if you can't find fresh berries and
fresh tropical fruits although it is
yeah that's all super great advice um
when I went to visit my aunt and uncle
in Indiana that this was when my oldest
was two years old so it was a while ago
but it was in the winter it was November
late November and I just didn't want to
eat as much like fruit because you know
you don't want want to have like a cold
smoothie when it's cold but I think a
lot of people think oh if I don't want
to do a smoothie or eat like Ellen and
Aaron then I can't eat plant-based but
you really don't have to be eating that
that way there's like a wide variety of
ways to eat whole plant foods and basing
your meals on all those bulk foods that
you just talked about is an incredible
way like you do not have to be like a
smoothie person to eat a healthy
plant-baside and it's totally especially
understandable when you're living in a
place with a cold climate where you just
might sure want it as much or maybe
you'll be doing
um fruit in a different way so like I
once made like a how I would eat in a
cold climate if like or how I would eat
vegan if I lived in a full climate and
we made this really awesome baked apple
dish where like we're having our fruit
but in a baked apple way with like
cinnamon and I think there was dates in
it I forget what we like poured it over
oatmeal and that is kind of how I
imagine that I would end up eating like
the type of the type how I would get my
fruit and but like greens are an easy
way to include it all kinds of things
like stews and salads it's not salads
don't have to be cold you know right so
and like that made me think we do like a
baked Berry oats dish with like I always
use the Frozen for that I'll just get a
big bag of mixed berries and like
sprinkled in and baked this really good
oat dish yeah it's it's amazing and yeah
totally and I always find it interesting
that when someone kind of brings up the
point that like well it's not
sustainable for the planet if you try to
eat vegan in a cold climate because we
should be eating like local meat instead
of importing fruit but I don't think
people are realizing how much energy and
pollution
um is is going into animal Foods even if
it's local like for sure the problem
with what's happening to our environment
and the pollution that's happening in
regards to animal agriculture the amount
that goes into it just being shipped
across the world versus the actual
intensity of growing the crops to feed
the animals or or just having the land
that is for the the animals is it is
more it causes more energy and pollution
than even if you were to eat imported
fruit and I know that's a controversial
statement that's something that people
are like what are you talking about but
it's it's the truth go go check out
Nicholas Carter he's an amazing
ecologist that talks all about that and
on Simon Hills podcast I'm gonna be
getting him on my podcast soon I'm
excited to have him on
um but I think a lot of people don't
realize that like just because you're
buying animal Foods locally doesn't mean
you're actually
um doing these monumentally great things
for the planet versus if you were to buy
fresh produce that is shipped somewhere
so because people are only kind of
considering the shipping part as opposed
to the growing aspect there's problems
in plant agriculture too but a lot of
people don't realize that how many
plants are grown to feed the animals
right they were filtering we're losing
upwards of like 60 of the calories so
it's like double yeah they just think
the animal but they don't realize how
much energy and waste it takes to grow
the animal and how much land it takes
through the plants that grow that are
grown to be the animal like I don't know
the exact percentages but like the soy
that's grown in America or just across
the world like the amount of it that
goes towards animal farming like to feed
animals compared to actual just humans
it's the mass majority to the animals oh
soy it's destroying the planet it's
those vegans but most of the soy is not
going yeah for sure and again I think it
goes back to like just like you can't be
Invincible on any diet there is no
perfect diet out there like there's no
perfect diet there's no perfect religion
like there's flaws and like pros and
cons to all of these things but I'm
always like what's my best route to like
live a life of longevity where I'm also
feeling my best every single day and
when you look at a plant-based diet all
across the board it's like it's better
for my health it's better for the
animals and it's better for the
environment like that is a win-win-win
so rather than getting too caught up in
the weeds I'm just like I like my odds
best yeah living this way yeah and you
kind of have to do that with anything
with the church you go to with the
friends you make like you can't have
everything in common with every friend
that you make you just have to be like I
like my odds best with this one yeah
totally bringing this up isn't to be
like isn't to put anyone down who's like
I'm choosing locally you know raised you
know animal foods and it's better for
the environment this is not to be like
just put you down for choosing local for
anything it's more just pointing out to
the factor of hey if you're buying a
porter bananas like that's bad for the
environment and so you shouldn't eat
that way
um I feel like there's so much more
layers and Nuance to that also it's
super interesting because someone might
say well oats and beans are important
but I'm really curious what the person's
saying that is eating because like all
processed foods are important like
almost all of them like you're not
getting your processed packaged food at
the grocery store from down the street
so like it's all important everywhere so
even if you're buying beans from
somewhere else like where are you
getting all your food unless you're just
eating local meat and dairy like we're
like in the winter places like that is
really interesting to me it's an
interesting conversation and I planted
yeah really good
swingers crossed that it happens
I really wish this wouldn't close
because then I could just look at it
Lauren now there's two times where I had
to stop my conversation she'll remember
right right
so let's get into a little bit about
your choice to move to Florida and just
moving far away I think a lot of people
are inspired by that on your journey of
choosing to start over and do things
differently and some people might feel
stuck in their situation so let's hear a
story on that yeah I mean Nebraska will
always always be home because that's
where our family is but I never really
felt completely like I fit in there and
we've always wanted to experiment with
growing our own foods and just living
near the sea and having somewhere where
our kids can be outdoors year round
um
and the thing that afforded us that
ability to be able to just up and move
and to travel for extended periods of
time
um is doing what we do online which is
our our business full-time now which we
never envisioned that being the case
whatsoever but it kind of just started
out like as I was on this healing
journey and I'm like I'm feeling so
super good like and then when you have
friends that finally start to reach out
and say what was in that green smoothie
you made I'm like I need to start a blog
like I need to figure out who I am I
need a place to share for others so if I
can have my PR my papa my passion
coupled with you know serving a purpose
for others I'm like that's awesome so I
started the blog and then eventually it
grew into like more and more posting on
Instagram and then we're like okay we
gotta try YouTube you know this is where
we're learning a lot of our stuff from
so we need to get on there too and share
our own view because quite honestly
everybody we follow was living this
tropical lifestyle and we were not so we
thought we had a unique perspective to
share
and it was
you know it grew from there to a point
where we could actually move and travel
and work completely online full-time and
so we're like well we would really kick
ourselves if we didn't at least try to
move somewhere like maybe we'll end up
back in Nebraska I don't really know but
we're like we owe it to ourselves to
give it a shot because so many people
just want to be able to be remote and
work online so we made the move in June
and so far it's been it's had its ups
and downs for sure and we've had moments
of homesickness and we haven't really
found our tribe yet but there are so
many Pros right now that we're really
enjoying it like I said being outdoors
planting our first banana plants and
mango trees and avocados and I feel like
we'll really begin to actually see the
fruits of our labor as those you know
mature and uh continue to try and find
community and I'm so grateful for the
online community
um I I know that social media gets a bad
rep but overall it's like overwhelmingly
positive because whenever we've been
lacking in community whether it be like
we're the only vegans in Nebraska we've
found such a good Community with like
our eat move rest fam and just finding
you know starting up random
conversations with other people in
Florida now who have things in common so
that's been really helpful yeah and I
think you and I are in the same boat
where we moved somewhere that we didn't
have friends or family really and kind
of started started over a lot of people
have
um concerns or it might just be a little
scared to do that or some people do make
a move and they feel lonely because they
don't have a community right away and I
totally understand that like for us it
definitely took at least a few years
before I felt like I really had a
community yeah but because I knew what I
wanted like we were just Andrew and I
just very like we know what we want in
like almost everything it's very rare
where I'm like I don't know what to do
right now with my life like that's just
how I've always been there just that
type of person and so we knew the
long-term gain and so I'm like you know
what just just stick to it keep working
hard Andrew was working so much when we
first got here at two different jobs and
we were just hustling to try to save as
much as we could you know to buy our
first house and just over time we
developed friendships and it just wasn't
something that happened overnight but a
lot of people do move I think places and
yeah and struggle if they don't have
um like a community right away I
definitely I definitely it was hard for
a little bit like there were times you
know like oh man like I would really
like to meet some people and it just it
took time but then eventually it kind of
unfolded so has that how's that been
like for you once you've moved to
Florida yeah it's been similar and I
feel like we all go through like what I
like to call like these incubation
phases in life where we have moments
where we are like in full bloom and like
we have the community and we have all
the things and we feel so at peace and
so grounded and then other times where
we're like kind of closed off and we're
incubating or we're like in this cocoon
stage and I feel like it's just a sign
that you might be be going undergoing a
metamorphosis like you might be changing
and growing and evolving and you need
that time to incubate to fully develop
before you can fully bloom again as a
newer better version of yourself so I
think it just really requires a lot of
patience especially when you make a move
away from everybody and everything like
finding a new Workout Studio finding a
new favorite coffee shop a new Farmers
Market new friends new neighbors like
it's gonna definitely take time you have
to at least I've heard give yourself a
full calendar year even to experience a
different climate like you don't know
what it's going to be like Florida has a
very wet rainy season and a lot of
people don't like that
um and so I think giving yourself a full
year but obviously a lot of times it's
going to take more time than that even
so patience is Paramount but I think
even more importantly I keep telling
myself in the back of my head you can
always make a change like no matter how
big and dramatic your move is or your
shift in life you can always go back
like if ultimately the you know this
unsettled feeling doesn't go away and
you don't find your groove you can
always make the change again you can
always course correct yes I love that
because sometimes people can feel a
little bit like oh man I made the wrong
choice and now I'm back pedaling
whatever but there really is no back
pedaling like it is your everything is
your journey so you're learning from
every situation and there's ways to grow
through every like through all all
things you experience like one of my
favorite podcasters ritual has said like
you'll know it's time to make a big
change when the fear of staying the same
is scarier than the fear of of changing
yeah and so if you're feeling like that
in any aspect of your life it's
definitely time to remind yourself you
really truly only do live once
and you never know what tomorrow holds
so it's it's worth it to go for it and
you can always go back yeah and for
people who are feeling kind of stuck in
life like you show you post a lot about
like mindful living and mindful
consumption or just like avoiding the
Mindless consumption and being a
creative can you share a little bit
about that as well because I I find that
really a fascinating topic how you know
if you're in a rut where you feel like
you're just mindlessly consuming and
maybe maybe you might be feeling down
inside like you're not doing what you
want to be doing in life what do what
can people take away from the stuff that
you're sharing to get into that creative
mode yeah for sure
um that doesn't mean you have to create
you have to be like a Creator on content
creation it could be any type of
creation I think yeah the Mindless
scrolling it's like I'm guilty of it we
all are at some point but like really
recognizing when that's happening too
often and reeling back and being like
maybe I'll create a post
and if you're feeling insecure about it
and you're not used to posting like you
don't have to post a picture of yourself
or a video or whatever just keep it
simple maybe it's like an open journal
entry to yourself that you want to share
with the world like just get something
out there and if it's not on social
media maybe you need a break from the
digital world and screen time in general
which I also highly recommend like maybe
if you used to play piano like I've I've
told myself these are my four things for
the next four years until I turn 40. I'm
going to learn a second language I'm
gonna dabble in like either piano or
guitar which I both used to play and
um there was two more I'm I'm blanking
right now but the idea is yeah you know
like just just start something you don't
have to become a professional at it but
like I've always heard that
um if you don't have an action plan then
like your goal is basically meaningless
you can have a a future goal but it's
not going to make any sense if you don't
um start with a small step so there has
to be something that you can do right
now today
and that feels like it puts the pressure
on but it's it could be the smallest
teeniest tiniest thing to get you there
um so maybe like for me on the flight
here I watched a Spanish movie with
English subtitles because I wanted to
start absorbing more of the Spanish
language which I studied in high school
and really enjoy it so I'm like that was
one small step and it was really
enjoyable I got really into the movie
because I'm like I can't be looking at
my phone because I'm reading subtitles
otherwise I'll miss the movie and so I
think just little tiny things and just
like breaking it down and also another
huge thing is like
okay this is where I want to be then you
just have to work it backwards like as
an example when we have to go somewhere
like with the kids it's so much more
work so I'm like we have to be there at
1 30. so it takes me an hour to get
ready so 12 30 it takes me a half hour
to get the kids ready minus another 30
minutes it takes us 30 minutes to eat
minus another 30 minutes and like work
it back until like what time do I have
to get up in the morning to make all of
this happen in a streamlined efficient
manner so
you can really do the same thing when
it's like your big life purpose or goals
and how do I get there like what do I do
today just start at the end and work it
backwards until you get to like the
teeniest most minute thing that you can
do that's gonna be a drop in the
confidence jar like oh I did something
yay like making your bed in the morning
like simple things like that they give
us confidence without us even realizing
it so I love that that's super helpful
and it also depends on like people's
personalities on like what what way is
going to be motivating for them but I
love that I love that message it just
starts something just do something
creative and that doesn't mean it has to
be anything for your job like you said
just just get in a creative mode that
does wonders for your mind for sure so
shifting gears here something that we
share in common a lot is Raising healthy
kids so we talk about raising our
healthy plant-based kids for sure what
what have you found to be your favorite
aspect about this or
um some tips in regards to ranging
healthy children
I just feel like I've conditioned my
mind just by being conscious over the
years of like
what is in a food like this is like a
healthy carbohydrate this is a healthy
fat this is a healthy protein and I know
about all of these antioxidants and all
of these different teeny tiny components
that go into these foods and so just
truly visualizing
um every bite that we take every bite
they take even if like we don't notice a
physical like manifestation right away
like at a cellular level just thinking
about nourishing your cells nourishing
your gut bacteria so just feeling so
empowered every time we eat together as
a family is like super super exciting
and rewarding because for me like when I
started before we had kids food was just
basically like how can I like get this
lean physique and look my best and have
good digestion and it was just like this
tool and I feel like it became like
food to like when we had a family it
became soul food it's like it's where we
connect and you know like I said the
cellular thing it's just it's taking on
a whole different meaning but
that being said like even if you're
it doesn't matter what diet you're on
you're probably gonna have days where
your kids are picky eaters and they
instead of eating The Gourmet beautiful
meal you made them they flop it on the
floor and it splatters the white chair
in the corner which just happened the
other day and I'm just like some days
it's just so stressful I'm like
the food isn't nourishing them if
they're not eating it you know some days
you will encounter that and you just
have to keep bringing your body going
through the motions putting the plate in
front of them keep trying keep trying
and eventually they they eat it yeah and
I think being the example is like goes
the farthest way sometimes I'll talk to
parents people say my kid won't eat
grapes you know this is not even like a
plant-based person but it's someone
who's like my child just won't eat fruit
you know and then I don't want to buy
the fruit because they don't eat it I'm
like well if you don't buy it how are
they gonna ever have the chance to
change their mind and eat it and are you
eating fruit and she's like well not
really I'm like well you need to eat the
fruit too sure there was an Instagram
post like that it was so funny it was
this little cartoon and the little girl
wanted to grab a cookie off the cookie
tray and she's like not till after
dinner and then the girl disappears into
the other room and the mom like sneaks a
cookie and it's like we're all so guilty
of like having different rules and
standards for ourselves and our kids and
they definitely see that yeah like you
know Dusty has been guilty of that with
like we'll get like a good loaf of
sourdough with like our chili and Max
just wants to eat the sourdough and
Dusty's dipping the sour in his chili
and Max has to finish his bowl before he
gets the breakfast
so it's like we do have these double
standards that yeah I don't know but if
you can like make your kids part of the
process from start to finish like take
them to the grocery store make it fun
and exciting by letting them get to pick
whatever colorful fruit or vegetable
they want to put in the cart or better
yet even help them grow grow it yeah
that's it's so exciting for like I was
just talking to Max about like how a
seed actually becomes a plant which
becomes that giant palm tree in the yard
and to actually get to see that process
is probably really cool so we're excited
to start our garden and we've watched
you guys grow all of yours and yeah that
always helps like the kids just love
their vegetables like yeah I'm gonna
grab the lettuce and the basil and the
arugula and yes they'll even eat a
little bit of arugula yeah spicy but a
few of them like the little ones not
quite yet but the older ones well and
then just all the tomatoes and kales
yeah like you know getting the measuring
spoons and making the muffins with Mom
and like getting even the little stair
stepper Max likes to go grab that yeah
and unfold yeah for sure and everything
by himself it's really also about
delaying the ultra processed foods
because you know when my friend who said
her child won't eat fruit it really
comes down to because fruit is one of
the most natural human foods that there
is like like we should be loving fruit
in its natural state is a it's a perfect
human food so if a child is not liking
fruit or an adult a lot of it the times
it really just comes down to what their
palette is used to and if your palette
is used to ultra processed foods then
the simple flavors of fruits and
vegetables just don't taste any tastes
good anymore or they just won't ever
taste good something as simple as like a
homegrown cucumber will taste or an
organic cucumber for the farmers market
it will taste amazing to a child if they
don't have the um the palette of ultra
processed foods yet so it's about
delaying the processed foods but then
you know once they're getting older I
found because your child you have four
and 18 months for anyone listening right
yeah and I found once the kids get a
little bit older like you really like
for instance when they're going to a
friend's party and so like that like the
kid is your child is going to feel the
most Freedom they can make the choices
that they want to make So eventually
like those types of foods are gonna
enter into the the diet or to the family
culture at some point right for the kids
right and it really just comes down to
just the majority of what you're eating
so the majority of what you're eating
and then seeing the way that their
parents eat for me something like a
salad like I don't have to make salads
for my little ones like Elvis and kofax
or Elvis and Sandy will be like yes
please make me a salad and then the
younger ones I just make a big salad for
myself knowing that the other two are
gonna come crawl on me and want to eat
some of myself same if I ask do you want
me to make you a salad they say no what
if I just make a salad for myself what's
mom got over there oh that looks pretty
good can I get that avocado can I get
that lettuce right there oh not that
bite I want that bite right there that
one that one like tomato and the avocado
and the lettuce so then they just enjoy
the food with you yeah and that becomes
part of the culture so really if that's
what you're eating and that's what's in
your house
Seafoods and that's not to say we don't
ever enjoy processed foods and processed
foods has a uh different levels right
for sure more processed than others we
do have some processed foods in the
house it's just that's not a dominant
part of our of our diet we don't take
something like chips or even something
like pretzels everywhere we go we're
grabbing the apple or a healthy food bar
we do do like healthy plant-based food
bars that's a great a great um way to
get you know a filling filling snack in
if you're on the go we like go macro
bars do you guys ever eat those yeah
yeah so there are those types of foods
but it's the majority of what we're
making is from scratch right that's what
we're doing right yeah and that cubes a
healthy palette so that when you're when
your child is out and about and choosing
what to eat more often than not they're
not choosing the processed foods or if
they do choose it they'll eat a little
bit of it and not a whole bunch of it
because they're just they're so used to
definitely notice that with Max yeah if
you know if we have birthday cake or
whatever like he already knows like when
when he eats a bunch of fruit how good
he feels and like he can eat a bunch and
enjoy it but with cake it's almost like
so super sweet he doesn't need a lot and
he knows how to say no like enough is
enough yeah and then like afterwards
it's so cute sometimes to be like Mom I
feel really sugared out
so cute yeah
he knows how he feels after this
he's not part of his normal natural
everyday diet yes absolutely I I've
definitely found that to be true in our
kids case too they don't want to eat a
lot of the super processed dense sugary
stuff because they eat a few bites and
like I'm good or maybe they'll be
excited to have it they'll have like a
bunch and then next time they're not
choosing as much there's so many moms
out there I have to bring this up
there's so many moms that are like I
wish I would have started my kids from
birth or when they were little like
yours or I wish I would have had that
and I'm like I get it I wish that too
but like the exciting thing is like
going all the way back to Dr esselstyn
like the first thing that I saw that
really resonated with me was like it's
never too late to start like you can be
86 years old with heart disease and
there's still a pretty good potential
that you can reverse some of that damage
if not all of it so it's never really
too late to start I I love that message
never too late to to start eating well
Living Well moving well and resting well
like you said and the moving and the
resting well I think this is a great
place to end it yeah I think that's the
Great conversation thank you guys for
being here we have a few more days
together that we get to spend off camera
and I'm excited for the more meals yes I
know so good meals we hope you guys
enjoyed this conversation and we will
see you next video thanks for having me
[Music]